let's talk about Iowa we still as of
this recording don't have final results
from the Iowa caucus the first in the
nation primary which took place on
Monday night it is time now to just very
clearly say with no ifs ands and buts no
caveats no restrictions whatsoever
Iowa can't get the privilege of being
the first to vote in primary elections
anymore
period . now there are a whole bunch of
reasons for this and most of the reasons
why Iowa actually shouldn't be the first
to vote have nothing to do with the
fiasco from Monday night the benefit of
the Fiasco from Monday night if there is
one if there is a silver lining is that
it's a good opportunity to put back in
the spotlight that Iowa should not get
the privilege of being first to vote
it's nothing personal against Iowa or
Iowans Iowans they're perfectly nice
people the ones that I've met but this
is a much bigger problem that we are
dealing with here first and foremost
Iowa is not remotely representative of
the Democratic electorate nor of the
country's demographics in any way
there's just no factual reason there's
no empirical case for Iowa getting to be
the first to vote when it comes to race
and ethnicity it's very obvious Iowa and
New Hampshire the first two to vote are
90 percent white the country is 60
percent white when it comes to economics
when it comes to education there is no
mathematical or empirical justification
for Iowa being the place where it makes
sense to start and going first does
carry disproportionate influence over
the eventual subsequent primaries
there's a good Vox piece from a couple
of days ago which reminds us that there
was a 37 point swing in the national
polls when John Kerry won in Iowa and
New Hampshire 16 years ago in the 2004
Democratic primary now then we get to
the disaster on Monday night the fiasco
Monday night with the app crashing and
the results being delayed an immediate
foul play and conspiracy theories
exploding it doesn't help Iowa's case
and it is another reason for
realistically not even having a single
state be the first to vote but instead
having a number of states being the
first to vote you could organize this
any number of different ways you could
say well we will divide the country into
regions will have the Northeast and the
southeast and will have the West Coast
whatever and we will have one state from
each region vote first on the first
primary day or we could say if we really
are convinced that we want to have one
state go first and one state only which
I don't think makes sense you could at
least rotate the state or you could pick
a different state that is more
demographically representative of the
country like for example Illinois is
often mentioned because of its racial
and ethnic and educational breakdown as
compared to the country at large it
would be a much better fit you could use
similar metrics other good options for
which states should go first if we're
trying to have a state that's
representative of the country you could
look at New Jersey you could look at New
York you could look at Florida it
doesn't have to be a blue state remember
it's the Democratic primary that we're
talking about and this is also a good
time to mention that there is nothing in
the Constitution about how primaries are
supposed to be run a lot of people don't
realize that the Democratic and the
Republican parties these are not
government entities and primaries are
not real elections in a sense in a sense
they are but in a sense they are not and
what I mean by that is that the process
and the rules and the parameters for
these primaries are decided on by the
parties and the members of the parties
and of course at the state level and
we're gonna get to that because that is
a factor back in 2016
you could tell a lot of people didn't
realize that parties decide how to run
the primaries because people were
looking at what the DNC did in terms of
how they structured the debates and how
they helped Hillary Clinton as maybe
being illegal it was not illegal this it
was not a legal issue with the DNC did
in 2016 now you do have state law and
state constitutions that make this more
complicated you have for example lots of
states have laws about when the primary
is supposed to happen Iowa says that its
caucus must happen eight days before any
other states proceedings that's why New
Hampshire is eight days after Iowa's
caucus New Hampshire has a law that says
they must be the first primary which is
why Iowa goes first but it's a caucus
and not a primary
so I don't want to pretend that getting
States to change their laws about this
is easy it's difficult for sure but the
DNC can push them if they want to it's
not clear that the DNC wants to change
the system that we have so much like the
electoral college more broadly we are
dealing with what are effectively
outdated and broken systems at this
point even the delegate system needs to
be reformed you could do a national vote
in the entire country on the same day
with instant runoff voting at the state
level giving everybody more equal say
and equal influence regardless of where
it is that they live my preference would
be to come up with a way to have more
states go first if not all or to rotate
who gets to go first why would it be bad
for Connecticut Democrats or Washington
State Democrats to go first every once
in a while it wouldn't be unless you
want to perpetuate the DNC's
stranglehold and influence over the way
that this is run that being said this
will not solve if you have a different
state go first that state still has
disproportionate power and influence and
makes a bigger impact and that is
ultimately something that the DNC wants
because it makes the primary easier to
control also just as a coda the first
primary shouldn't be a caucus and in
fact I would support getting rid of
caucuses altogether period and any
process that involves coin flips and
requires hours of participation is
outdated I won't call it bad it's just
not realistically fine-tuned and a good
process in 2020 change my mind I want to
hear from you I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
follow me there we'll take a quick break
and be back right after this